hi and welcome to crash course
cryosphere I'm Simon I'm Tom this week
I'm going to be looking at the physics
of stress and strain and looking at the
umbrella field of rheology whereas I
will be looking at the internal
deformation of ice and how this helps
glacés flow previously we discussed that
an important factor in mass balance is
the movement of ice from the
accumulation zone uphill to the ablation
zone downhill Glacia flow transfers ice
from high elevation accumulation areas
to low elevation ablation areas and this
flow is the reason why glacier is a
particularly effective at sculpting and
changing the landscape creating
everything from huge u-shaped valleys to
terminal moraines why am I telling you
all this is it because we lost some of
our footage absolutely not but just how
does all of that terrestrial ice move
down sloped on part of our answer need
to look at individual ice crystals and
how they behave when stacked upon one
another hundreds if not thousands of
meters deep we do this through the two
concepts of stress and strain and we
look at these two concepts under the
umbrella of biology geology is quite
simply how a given material responds to
a given stress and strain now for this
we really need Simon's help it's time to
get into some more physics it's what we
worked on oK you've used a whole bunch
of new words there we were kind of going
to need to define what they mean we're
going to need to go on a definition
spree here stress is defined as the
force per unit area easy to remember
because physicists who deal with forces
are always under a lot of stress at the
base of a glacier the normal stress
acting on the bed is due to the weight
of the ice above it strain is defined as
the relative change in the size of an
object in response to a given stress so
strain is the change in the length scale
of an object divided by the original
length scale of that object strain rates
are defined in terms of velocity
gradients so how quickly that change in
length scale is taking place and there
lots of kinds of strains but we're not
going to go into that complexity here
reality then is the study of how
different substances respond to given
stress
and strains and in particular we're
interested in the yield strength so how
much stress and strain an object can
take before it deforms this yield
strength is determined by a whole number
of different factors which we don't have
time to talk about here but if you'd
like to learn there's a link down there
in the description to further reading a
powerful framework for understanding
Glacia dynamics in other words how the
item moves over time is what's known as
the force balance this is the balance
between the driving stresses of the
weight of ice member a mass of ice under
gravity and the push back the resistive
stresses due to the bed and the walls of
the valley in which the glass is being
contained now in an idealized situation
these two are balanced but glacis move
over time so clearly some of the time
this isn't the case now we've got that
sorted I'm going to hand back over to
the gravel monkey so using this we find
that under long timescales ice is
actually a plastic material this means
that it will deform under force
permanently without breaking this may be
counterintuitive if you're used to
finding ices of brittle material for
example is a puddle now it's not to say
ice is not still behave brutally it
still does in terms of iceberg carving
but fundamentally under long timescales
in the masses we find it it is a plastic
material and it's this plastic and its
ability to deform it is so crucial to
glacier flow so what force is a glacier
responding to well actually is
responding to its own weight it's just
experiencing the certain thickness of
ice is given by this equation
where Rho the P looking guy is the
density of the ice G is the Earth's
gravitation acceleration and H is the
thickness above a certain point if the
ice we're considering was a parallel
slab on a flat plane and of course we
wouldn't see any movement or the forces
directed immediately down however this
isn't the case in reality and most
places are located on slope of some kind
this introduces a downslope component to
the stress and the shear stress and
fundamentally this is what's causing ice
to flow according to Newton's third law
we know there must be an opposing force
in glacier systems this is primarily
basal drag basal drag is quite simply
the friction that is generated as the
ice flows over whatever surface it is on
additional force comes from friction
with the sidewalls and longitudinal
forces from up and downstream ice
okay so what we're trying to do here is
demonstrate all those processes we
discussed in action in this bowl I've
got a whole bunch of plaster palace I'm
clearly agitated to try and get the air
bubbles out and we're hoping this is a
viscous enough solution that it will
behave like a glacier when we pour it
down this icelandic valley system in the
valley at the base here we've got a
small over deep ling at the back a
general ledge and then a sudden
acceleration down onto the front where
hopefully we'll get a few more lobe type
formation as ever with our
demonstrations
we'll see what actually happens okay so
now we're going to pour the glacier into
the mountains never done this before so
let's see what happens
third to viscous fortunately it looks
like it started to set so we're gonna
try and add some water to it you can see
the idea of what's supposed to happen
here around our mouth of cake yep of two
thick plaster palace but it's slowly
creeping down the hillside under its own
weight
and now just an extra bit of hillside
assistance we're going to push it down
into the valley just scoop it up a bit
as it spills out the bottom of the
valley it spreads out onto the flat
plane and just for the sake of artistry
I'm going to smooth the top of it so now
we have our glacier in place and as you
can see our demonstrations are trying to
follow a pattern now of minor success
followed by minor disaster and we at
least have a glacier in place as kind of
spreading out to the PMR lobe at the
bottom now up at the top here where we
saw the over deepening what's happening
is the force is pushing down and into
the over deepening and then the ice
comes up and over the lip as we move
down the glacier that forces angled down
the slope and is pushing the ice down we
reach the bottom here as you can
actually see with the plaster and power
as well the slopes on these stops you
could end up on a flat plane and due to
that this is why you get this a low
baked form at the end as the ice comes
down off the slope and a spreads out
to the flat plane having decided some
grasses in with a piece of cardboard
we've I've concentrated the classes at
the lip of the over deepening and again
at the downslope break here this is
because I see at these points the
longitudinal stresses increase and the
ice cracks apart remember ice was
plastic is still fundamentally brittle
in many ways right with that done the
light failing and plastered prowess
caking my hands we'd better get on the
decimation of ice in response to stress
can occur through either creep or
fracture we know that ice is a plastic
material and it will respond to the
stress in the ways we've already
discussed this deformation is measures
the strain which is a unitless measure
the displacement we can also discuss
this in terms of strain rate which is a
measure of strain over time the amount
of strain that takes place for given
stress it's described by Glen's flow law
so I run don't worry tom I'm here it's
all gonna be fine we're going to talk
through this equation which give it its
full title by the way which I think it
deserves
it's nice generalization of Glen's flow
law this equation here isn't anything to
be scared of maths isn't here to
intimidate us it's actually here to help
us in our understanding in the natural
world
often people find maths hard my I
personally think that's because they
think it's hard once you realize that
math is actually quite easy you suddenly
find it easy and the first step to that
is to stop being intimidated by
something like this even Tom can do it
all this equation is saying is how the
rate of change of strain in the system
depends on the stresses in the system
plus a whole bunch of other numbers and
constants that come from the geology to
break down this equation from left to
right them on the left hand side we have
what looks like an e but it's not it's
actually the letter epsilon which is a
Greek letter we use Greek letters in
sine sometimes because we run out of
normal letters and sometimes for
historical reasons in this case it
refers to the strain of the system well
actually not quite it refers to the
effective strain of the system because
underneath the epsilon there's a capital
letter E which refers to the fact that
it's the effective strength now above
our strain we had a little dot that dot
is just a very lazy way that we describe
the rate of change of something
if you have X with a dot above it that
means the rate of change of X so what
we're looking at here is how the strain
changes in time
physicists are lazy we love doing things
with shortcuts a little dot topknot
that's what we have on the left-hand
side and then this equals some number a
now a is what we call a parameter it
might not necessarily represent
something physically directly but it can
depend on variables and in this case a
very strongly depends on the temperature
in fact it exponentially depends on the
temperature so if you change the
temperature of your IC o---- glacier a
little bit you change a a lot and what
we're doing is timesing that by this
thing on the right was T looking guy
this again is another Greek letter it's
not actually T its towel and towel here
represents the stress but wait it
doesn't because we have a catalytic a
underneath it which means it's the
effective stress and above it we have a
little n if n was to be replaced by 2
you could recognize this straight away
it will just be tau squared it's just
the power of tau now in geology we like
to sort of match equations for the data
we make assumptions so it actually turns
out that n is around 3 3 is a pretty
good approximation but it's just a
number it's just tell approximately
cubed so the rate of change of the
strain in the system is equal to some
number that depends on the temperature
strongly depends on the temperature
times the stress of the system note by
the way the a doesn't just depend on the
temperature actually depends on other
things like the water content the
impurities in the water and the size of
the ice crystals the key takeaway from
this equation is this that as you
decrease the temperature of ice or your
Glacia the ice starts behaving less like
a plastic deformable thing and more like
a solid this is similar to having a
chocolate bar in your back pocket it's
no longer solid but a bit gooey whereas
if you put the top lower back in the
fridge if they get colder and colder and
more and more solid all without
undergoing a phase change due to this
viscosity the actual method by which
deformation occurs is by ice creep this
is movement within or between ice
crystal
of course in reality you have impurities
and water content that means that this
perfect model does not always work it is
important to consider that the total
movement strain experienced at the
surface of the glacier is cumulative
rice creep is occurring at all levels
are the Glacia perhaps unsurprisingly it
sounds greatest at the base where the
pressure is also greatest if we assume
all of the above to be true we have a
problem according to what we've just
discussed the rate of flow should only
be millimeters to centimeters per year
but we have ice streams they're moving
at 25 kilometers a year additionally we
also see lots of seasonal variation
places often flowing faster in summer
than in winter but a depth of the ice
column is remaining relatively the same
so that can't be explained by the
mechanism of ice creep so have we got
ice creep wrong or is it actually tasted
than other processes at work here that
are serving to accelerate the ice in
ways that we haven't yet discussed this
way some must be cool because Ivan
allowed gloves because I'm talking about
touching this you have killed an alien
for us yeah
what is this well I can't maybe it's not
an alien and well maybe there's a clue
because I maybe we can read this it says
triwizard tournament on it any otherwise
is this support key close know what it
is it's part of what it called it on
which is a digital optical module so it
works would like and it's part of an
array that is used to detect neutrinos
that lives at the South Pole
so underneath the ice in the South Pole
for a kilometer cubes there are loads of
these things and they're strung up like
so like pearls on a string they go down
they go across and like I said kilometer
cube and they all speak to each other
and they're there to detect neutrinos so
it's a bit of physics yeah neutrinos are
these really don't leap articles that
those I think the statistic is
illuminating going through your
thumbnail in a given time they're
basically totally don't interact with
matter and not like electrons or protons
that have big signatures so detecting
them is a really difficult thing so the
huge physics experiment going on at the
South Pole kilometer cubed is a very big
experiment yet it's called the CERN of
the polar regions and it's on that kind
of scale already and it's been hijacked
like
monkeys like Tom to do geological
science because while it's detecting
neutrinos because it's a kilometer on
the surface of Io kilometer then it also
goes down by a kilometer these things
are being sort of sheared by the
movement of the ice since you're
actually learning a lot about the
movement of ice underneath the surface
but by very roundabout route yeah but
it's really precise because particle
physics
I mean fairly precise yeah and it's kind
of an unexpected benefit of it that
you've got yeah it's an excavator so
it's been used to find out quite a lot
about how the shape of the landmass
underneath the ice works and because
it's embedded in a glacier because of
the qualities of the icing iglasia which
means it's really good for the optical
properties yeah it's basically how else
would you've got that it's just that
really is novel how did they get it down
how to drill down what they did they
need colder so very pure hot water to
make the holes in problem in just for a
kilometer straight straight yeah another
question of course is why they called
the triangle yeah it's a good point and
each of the groups of these has a theme
so it's part of Harry potter-themed
group of domicile yes what would you
call them I reckon Stalin has to be one
I mean you have to be dealing with
physicists yeah so style or Star Trek
laws the rings it's probably babylon 5
and we were going for your article here
yeah Firefly yeah what you have to do
and this is just so cool I just kind of
want to take it apart and look at the
electronics but I won't because clean
I've got a travels attaching things
before yeah or they're actually that's
one of the reason we've got one at all
is because it was faulty so that's why
we were able to have one because each
one represents a fairly hefty and quite
expensive bit of kit this week we
covered that biology is the science of
stress and strain and the stress and
strain and how we think about a
materials behavior as it responds to
pressure that ice is a plastic material
on long timescales it retains brittle
behavior but ultimately behaves as a
very very viscous
plastic solid like a half melted
chocolate bar that Glen's flow law
describes how the rate of change of the
effective strain experienced by ice
depends on the temperature of the ice
and the stress that it's experiencing
but as Tom said in this cliff
ending glaciers move faster than the
equations and processes that we've
discussed this week can account for why
you have to tune in next time to find
out well I hope you enjoyed all of that
thank you very much for watching this
series if you have any questions about
the stuff we talked about this week then
Tom and I will be answering your
questions down there in the comments so
have any misconception something you're
worried about about the series not about
life in general and Tom and I will try
and answer those questions for you
there's also links to further reading in
the description so you will take your
understanding further which you should
because this that's awesome we'd like to
thank all of these people for helping
make this series possible we really
could have done it without you go in
particular the recover project
University of Exeter for having fun this
and the Scott Polar Research Institute
here in Cambridge for accommodating us
and being so incredibly helpful thank
you for watching there are more icy
adventures awaiting next week